growing up young around 8 years old girl
love for the sport my goal is to get to
the NBA and finally Moreno Valley
California I'm trying to go in and be my
own Clair I make a name for myself he's
one of the very best forwards in all of
college basketball you know I've been
working my whole life to get here I like
to win games and be a champion for
myself growing up in Tom door I knew I
loved the game I didn't know how far it
was gonna take me
I just feel like I got a lot of
potential to continue to grow you know I
think the sky's the limit the Indiana
Pacers select Paul George of Fresno
State University Kawhi Leonard from San
Diego State University who's the star in
the making
[Applause]
Lenard for prey
take six shear force and dominant man
choir are pretty close those two players
along with our roster and is deep they
are talented deep and stacked with you
start you know we both Southern Cal guys
why is a closer Paul George is a closer
George we both wanted to play for the
city the Los Angeles Clippers this is
something special
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Paul George and
Kawhi Leonard
politeknik some opening remarks thank
you oh man Wow
lost for words but that's dead dead I'm
extremely excited extremely happy to be
back home first and four months I just
want to thank the whole Thunder
organization mr. Bennet Sam Presti
what a partnership that we had there it
was a great two years there for me but
you know ultimately they uh you know
helped me find my way back home to LA
and very appreciative of that moment
it's pretty dope was pretty awesome I
remember when I was in Hindi and we
drafted Kauai I was a little confused by
it because I was the two guard there and
quiet was my position and I was a bit
nervous for that competition I was
coming but if we fast for that and
knowing what I know now being a player
that I am and the player he developed
into I wish we would have kept that pick
and I wish we would have progressed
together and we could have did some
special things in Indiana but it's great
to fast for it to where we are now we
both here in that leg it just seems like
it's this was destined we were supposed
to play together so here we are Thank
You mr. Baumer hello Frank
coach I'm looking forward to this
journey with you and man we're gonna
make it happen
lar way
and now the two-time Finals MVP Kawhi
Leonard
[Music]
oh yeah me too just before I get started
on clippers you know I want to think of
the trying to wrap their fans you know I
have social media so I'm not able to put
out a you know paragraph or whatever but
but like I was gonna say
just think of Toronto the city of the
country you know it was a great amazing
season best Parade ever thanks to the
doctors for you know delivering my baby
my baby boy he's three months now and
still healthy also wanted also we'll
just one of them you know thank the city
as far as the restaurants you know
giving up that Kauai and died throughout
the playoffs took advantage of that
you know the players they already know
what's up you know text FaceTime me
we'll talk culture staff as well and the
whole organization really just think the
whole city
thank you but now I'm on my next journey
these guys I think we got a great future
Paul is always a player that I wanted to
play with like you were just saying when
I got drafted to the Pacers I'm like
they already got a you know two-way
player pretty much but uh you know as
our careers moved forward you know I see
how he develops he'll develop and I
wonder if we would have stayed in
Indiana but you know we're here together
in LA both Southern Cal guys play right
down the street with each other
in a Honda Center not with each other
but game out there won another
championship game I've been watching
them since then but uh you know now we
own the Clippers and it is just I think
we got some special we could make
history here and you know we got the
right team to do it with Steve Lawrence
and doc the championship head coach and
I'm excited you know watching that video
that they just presented all ready to go
we're gonna open it up for questions
here in just a second there'll be some
wireless mics passed around we are live
on Fox so if you could please state your
name and affiliation and wait for the
microphone before you talk it would be
appreciated by all I'll start it off
Kauai I'll send it your way first what
does it mean to be playing basketball
for you here in Los Angeles in front of
friends and family means a lot to me you
know these are the Clippers probably one
of the first NBA games I came to I mean
obviously it's a different staff
organization now far as people that's
leading it but just be able to you know
from a fan of friends and family to you
know drive to a game and watch me play
and see no matter and able to just enjoy
the time here it's gonna be great Paul
how exciting is it for you that your
basketball career brings you back here
to Los Angeles I think the same is you
know what Kauai said you know just
family friends just being able to be
here full-time the interactions I can
have with you know people are grew up
with and people that's been around me
since I've been a kid I'm here you know
I'm able to be touched I'm able to you
know be here full time be around my
niece nephews my kids being here with
their niece or their cousins it's just
you know I think it's it's a great fit
all around I've always wanted to play
back home and see what that was like and
do something for my hometown so I think
now I'm here I can do that on a
full-time level raise your hand
name affiliation wireless mic should be
passed around of course the first
question always goes to Jim Hill first
of all client Paul congratulations
welcome home I know of the love that you
have for young people and the two-part
question I have is what does it mean to
you to have all these young people here
and this surroundings for your press
conference and the other is what was it
like and what was it about the Clippers
it made you want to play for them when
you had so many other options
for me I grew up a Clippers fan I love
the Clippers as a kid I think I answer
the first part first I think it's pretty
awesome I was as much as a Clippers fan
I was I was a Kobe fan and Kobe like was
my idol growing up so I think now with
what me and Kawhi can do we can you know
inspire that next generation to want to
go out on that Court I think how we play
is a lost art in the NBA where guys want
to get after it on both ends and that's
how Kobe was for me he was a guy that
didn't care who he matched up against
who he's gonna play against he wanted to
beat beat him on both ends and that was
what I was used to watching growing up
so I think for us we get that same
opportunity to give back to the next
generation and kind of rebrand
basketball in that sense but you know
Clippers been my team so you know for me
it was a chance to come back home and to
be a part of something that was already
special I'm not a guy that come in with
a ego with you know that I'm demand like
I want to be a part of something special
I want to help build something special
and you know this is surreal to be home
and do it for a team that I grew up and
wanted to be a part of ever since uh
they missed out on me in the draft but
that's another story
that wasn't all that wasn't on Steve's
time so so it's cool let that grillage
go away you know for me I just feel like
you know with dot being a championship
head coach you know that's something
that I wanted experience coach and the
front office's you know very uh
transparently you know they want to win
I want to win again and I'm just saw
opportunity for us to just build our own
you know what I mean to make history
they haven't been told finals they
haven't won of finals
so you know that was something big and
exciting for me to you know make my
decision
guys dan Waikiki with the Los Angeles
Times question for both of you
um there's a culture that's in place
here already this team they mentioned a
little bit of team that played a certain
style with a certain intensity last
season I'm curious how much of what was
here last year and sort of that identity
factored into your decision to be a
clipper I think it's just how I play you
know pretty much it's a good pair like
he says black top team they're going
hard on both ends of the floor
they want to win and that's kind of
pretty much my competitive mindset when
I step on the floor I'm not a big guy to
just have it all on me as far as I'm
seeking every attention you know if it's
not my night or not my game you know I'm
willing to you know pass the ball and do
what it takes to win I feel like they
have that culture here yeah I mean that
was the biggest attraction with just how
hard they play and I think we coached
out honestly getting everything out of
his players I mean that's that's such a
special gift when a coach can grab and
you could just see their connection on
the court you know everybody was on the
same page everybody was pulling for one
another and everybody elevated you know
their games so you know to be a part of
that that you know camaraderie to be a
part of it
what they already had is just sprinkling
what we know how to offer you know
that's that's what made it such an
attraction attractive you know spot for
me to be at I Ramona she'll run with
ESPN I'm gonna try to ask two questions
if you can just cuz I can I guess the
first question is just what
conversations have you guys had with Doc
about how you're gonna build this team
and how you're gonna play so far and the
second question is is simply what both
Kauai was a free agent Paul you got here
and in a different way but
but obviously it factors into this idea
that we have about player empowerment
and players getting to choose where they
want to be and be where they want to be
and just sort of your thoughts on where
you both rank in that conversation well
to answer the first question me and doc
still got a dinner to go to he blew me
off I'm house I'm pretty good excuse for
right now but you know I you know I look
forward to the dinner and getting to
really just unravel and um you know
figure out you know what he wants for me
what I need to do I mean go from there
and just with the whole player
empowerment stuff I mean I didn't do
nothing I was you know I work hand in
hand with the front office we had a
great relationship you know and we
played I played two good years there and
and you know it was a mutual thing
between both of us that you know the
time was was what's up and you know we
both had ideas of doing things
differently so I don't think there's
nothing wrong with it I think it should
be a mutual and and pretty even thing if
both parties can be on the same page at
the end of the day they got a career as
far as you know the team and the players
have a career as well so as long as
there's a mutual respect between the
both you know should be nothing wrong
with it